[Music]
Ganesh Bell president of uptake welcome
to Stanford thank you so much for coming
thank you thank you for having me here
well tell us a little bit about uptake
what is the company and who are your
customers what are you accomplishing in
the digital industrial transformation
sure so uptake we have a mission a world
that always works what it means is
simply we are in industries where their
asset centric these are the
infrastructure that powers a world and
we build a AI machine learning and IOT
platform on top of which we're building
applications and we're adding deep
industrial content content meaning we
understand that in many of these
industries there are critical assets so
we have a database of how all these acts
are going to fail
there's about we've catalogued about
55,000 work ways these assets are gonna
fail across may differ industries we
like to think of it as 5000 ways the
world will stop working so we apply
machine learning and data science to
make sure that we can actually predict
and therefore we can drive outcomes for
customers either its uptime reliability
but from there we can optimize the
entire business
well now previously you worked at GE you
were the chief digital officer for a
while you worked in in G power why did
you leave GE to go to a start-up which
is now a big startup like uptake
actually the most important thing is why
I came to GE the first place so I
remember when she called me more than
four and a half years ago they were
trying this idea of software I think
Jeff at that time the chairman of GE had
a belief that data and software will
fundamentally change the industry and I
had a similar belief that software will
reimagine businesses and industries as
we know it so I actually ended up
selling GE the idea of digital and ended
up being the first chief digital officer
and building the power digital business
so it was really a moment of do I
believe my own that businesses
and software will be reimagined with
software and I got a chance to go do
that at the biggest scale for a long
time and for about for more than four
years built a successful business in
digital for power which became the
blueprint for all of GE digital and
towards the tail end of my career where
you know some of the biggest believers
like Jeff had left and so my bosses had
left but I still believe that GE was a
fantastic company and a great company
but I also believe that the business MA
of doing digital was directly in
conflict with the existing business
model of doing services so I actually
believe that this has to be done in a
fiercely independent way and uptake was
the best thing out there and I joined
forces with the founder ice if you look
at uptake it looks like any digital
company we could see anywhere in the
world here in Silicon Valley Beijing
Shanghai Berlin how do you bring domain
knowledge of the industrial areas that
you're serving were they largely what
looks like a digital DNA company that's
a great question because if you think
about all these industries they've all
operated out with data to some extent
except they've been about first
principle physics based analytics right
and that was good enough to operate the
world where we only used a little bit of
the data but in the last five years I
would say machine learning and cloud
technologies have caught up to a point
where we can process all of the data and
with machine learning we can actually
surpass first principles physics based
analytics to get to truly predictive
analytics and so you really need machine
learning AI at the core of what you do
and that's what I have taken it done in
addition we'd actually bought the main
expertise with operators so our head of
energy was the head of being a power
president of power at excel on one point
and he was also the chief innovation
officer and chief information officer so
knowing that the main matters quite a
bit and we used to do ads in the past
that our data scientists wear steel-toed
boots and it's actually technically true
our data scientists visit a wind farm or
a mining operations and so it's
combining the domain and knowing people
who know the industrial aspect that's
why we also bought a company called
asset performance technologies where it
was about 32,000 man-hours of domain
expertise cataloging every single
critical asset how it fails were the
preventative maintenance strategies so
digitizing that and learning on top of
that is really where the value is last
week we had Sam Allen the CEO of
Caterpillar visitor systems leadership
class and he talked about what they're
doing on digitization how does a company
like uptake figure out where in the
technical stack you want to play and own
certain things and where you want to
partner with your industrial customers
actually I caterpillar is a customer of
ours we started our optic starter
journey with caterpillar there are many
divisions of caterpillar that deploy our
software
where we decide to play is very simple
which is there are many companies that
sell enabling technology in fact I would
say the industrial IOT there is a whole
new stack that's emerging right now it's
very similar to how it was in enterprise
software in the 90s where there was
database servers app servers integration
servers analytic servers applications
and so on and so forth great portal
servers and everything we kind of see
that again which is data aggregation at
the industrial sensor level there is
edge where you can draw on computing
there and there's also all the layers of
contextualizing data app platforms
analytical platforms tools and apps what
we do is platform which is really about
software to build software and so we can
help companies that are in industries
where they're actually digitally
backwards so they need high productivity
almost like bulletproof kind of a
platform where it's like bumper bowling
where every time you bowl you and a hit
a pin so if you build an app on our
platform you will build an app it's not
left to some IP magic and on top of that
we're building applications but where we
really play is outcomes so we focus on
how do we impact the financial statement
of our customers which means either
reduct reducing operating and
maintenance cost or improving their
output or improving their uptime so if
we start there the CEO cxo level we can
work backwards we're not a ashor we're
not AWS we love all of those guys we run
on top of them all right so you talked
about enterprise software and the
enterprise internet and some you know
you were at Oracle for a while s ap how
is the industrial internet different
than how we might think about the
enterprise of the enterprise Internet or
the consumer Internet it's a great
question actually if you take a step
back compare price software is not a
very long running discipline where it's
only a few decades old right and I would
argue that we're actually at a seminal
moment in just history of enterprise
software why do I believe that in the
last several decades enterprise software
was all about humans entering data and
automating business processes that was
true till now but now we're in a world
where machines are generating data
robots and drones are increasingly at
work with wearables and humans augmented
by machines are generating more data so
we believe there were
being a paradigm of where it's about
automating decisions versus automating
business processes that's fundamentally
different and the next thing is we see
that in many of these industries that
have been left behind industrial world
especially there is a separation that's
happening between what I call the
physical model of the industry which is
assets and labor and parts and people
and the economic model more importantly
the future economic model if you take a
utility for example it's no longer about
producing electrons it's about selling
services beyond the electron so as the
gap becomes wider there's a bigger value
creation opportunity and I also believe
that the technology shift is happening
if you think about enterprise software
history or you meant from mainframe the
client-server it was a new market we're
going from client-server to distributed
computing new market when we went from
distributed to SAS it was a replacement
market so far we only redid what we did
in a new architecture we never
reimagined I think that re-imagination
is gonna happen right now and that's why
we believe it's going to be very
different so one of the things we've
learned about the industrial market is
it's not as quick to change some other
market segments yeah how does an
independent company like uptake think
about its rate of growth you've taken
venture capital money how do you think
about traditional metrics that might
come from a technology company but
applying to a market that sometimes
takes a little bit longer to evolve and
accept new ways of doing things yes so
startups are gonna be always different
than large companies where when I was at
GE and running a very large P&L it was
about operating profit every quarter
right whereas in a start-up it's really
about growth customer acquisition and
onboarding new customers so we have lots
of proxy metrics we actually measure
things like for example how many hours
are our algorithms trained on for
example some of our predictive machine
learning algorithms are mesh trained on
over 1.2 billion hours of operating data
right that's an important metric for us
how many models are we deploying how
quickly can we deploy new data science
models but at the end of the day we're
gonna measure things like orders
bookings and how we're growing the
customer but you're right that these
industries are long sales cycle so the
question is can we actually do quick
wins and also there
some fast more sometimes will do lumpy
big bills and the art is moving from the
lumpy big deals to a volume revenue
engine and I think that's the real
challenge
organizer is fascinating to see how
uptake is entering this market as an
outside player we really appreciate your
coming to Stanford to discuss systems
leadership and thank you so much for the
time it's great thank you
thank you for having me all of us
[Music]
you